good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Monday it is sunny and bright and
delicious in New York it's like God knew
that we were recapping love is blind and
gave us a beautiful day to do so we love
to see it we really do it was actually a
beautiful weekend in New York City
stunning and I don't know I feel like
spring is springing it was really one of
those days I only left my house over the
weekend to walk Theo and every time I
left I was like oh this is nice
did the groundhog see his shadow this
year because I feel by the way that was
gonna happen yeah that it no it's
February 2nd his grand honks today it is
yeah and Groundhog Day is such nonsense
I just want to say I feel like when we
were younger we used to put so much
stock in together or not the groundhog
saw a shadow and like really please see
your shadow like we were so excited for
spring we were so dumb like it has
nothing like no it's the dump now that I
think about it is like we were
bamboozled hoodwinked and swindled into
thinking that the weather had anything
to do with the groundhog know and it's
like in this day and age when we have so
much data and science about like climate
change we're over here like relying on
some dumb [ __ ] groundhog to like tell
us what the weather is gonna be it's so
incredibly stupid I've decided I am my
own groundhog and spring has officially
sprung yeah no it's it's bringing
alright Pyo Chi be your own groundhog
but it's getting me excited for spring
but annoyed that I still have to wear
like winter clothes well today I feel
like you can definitely get away with a
light jacket yeah but I feel like I have
I've maxed out on my winter clothes like
yes oh by the way say I've worn
everything every different way like I'm
back to my sweater from two years ago
which is the sweater that I wear when I
feel a little chunky I like that sweater
umm I like it too but I'm just I'm
moving on you know moving on and get
nolde how was your weekend my weekend
was really great I did what I said I was
gonna do and I caught up on all TV I'm
caught up on siesta key
I'm caught up except for the last half
of last night's episode of shock oh I
didn't even watch last night's I watched
love is blind and I feel like I might
have watched something else too but I
don't know I'm totally caught up that's
what I wanted to do this weekend I
wanted to watch love is blind I wanted
to watch it just because I feel like
it's part of our job to just speak on
things that are being spoken about even
though like when it first started like
getting like excitement and there was
like a toasters group meeting about it
I didn't really like I don't know for
some reason I'm not yearning for new
reality and competition shows on Netflix
it's just I feel like my bucket when it
comes to reality shows is so full on
cable but I seek like drama and comedy
shows scripted shows from my streaming
services so when everyone was like
raving about the circle I didn't really
get into it just because I don't need
more reality shows on Netflix it's a
reality show thing I don't think the
circle was ever gonna be for us it's
very like competition driven like we're
not gonna be brother of Ivor right yeah
but like this is you know The Bachelor
Plus are you the one Plus every show
that we actually like and I wouldn't
watch it just because everyone like he's
watching it but I just knew that it was
gonna be something that we would like oh
no I didn't think I was even gonna like
it I watched it just because everyone
was watching and I feel like it's part
of our job to like be in the know and I
was like okay well is everyone getting
into and I think within 10 minutes I was
like obsessed with the show yeah what I
loved you about the show and we'll do a
full recap after this because I need to
go in I need we have so many dogs we
have so many thoughts but what I loved
about the show is like you think the
whole thing is the pod experiment and
the engagements and it's like the
engagements that's just the beginning I
people get engaged in the first episode
you know it actually has nothing to do
with it it did feel like two different
shows where in the first few episodes it
really felt like a way more serious
meaningful process and the second half
was giving me like a lot of Bachelor
vibes and like the forest weddings kind
of made it into like a little bit of a
joke towards the end so I did kind of
wish we had more time in the pods I
thought the pods were like so special
and I was like loving these
conversations and I could have used a
little bit more of that and a little
less like silliness everyone's drinking
wine on the same cup you know yeah okay
let's let's press pause because we'll
recap it at the end if you've seen it
you guys like let's chat we have a job
to do before that we do have a job to do
and I guess it's time I don't know it
just feels like super oh you know who I
saw at dinner last night no Sophia Ricci
oh when I saw your friend Hana oh you
did yeah and she was sitting at table
across me and so like we kind of I could
see each other and and then when Sophia
walked past like she was walking like a
famous person but I didn't catch who it
was and then on it was like to me do see
how that was it was like hey Sophia we
are at Nobu 57 Oh such like so much like
it's hard not to take no no I was just
like a bottomless pit of hunger I just
kept ordering sushi rolls good and now I
feel like a big
but today is the first day of the rest
of my life I know I say that like every
mother Monday um
but today I really mean it because I'm
getting sad you know okay um so do you
think we should just like do the damn
thing
I don't know how was Theo's weekend the
news weekend was very agoraphobic I've
been home alone now for three days cuz
Ben was in Palm Beach and it was okay
Saturday was tough for me I really don't
like being alone and Saturday like I was
just like dying to do something but I
also didn't want to leave my bed it was
like a terrible feeling and then I went
out on Saturday night like with my
friends had a few drugs at a good time
hey man I know I actually was on my way
downtown going to a party and the person
I knew at the party was like behind me
so I didn't want to get there before the
person so I was like right by markers
apartment and I just like unshod up
unannounced and like had a drink at her
place and like made her play her record
player for me because I didn't want to
be at this party before my friend um so
I spent like 20 minutes there but she
would like had her own plan she like
wouldn't even hang out with me
oh I mean I know the feeling she's so
mean to me these days like god forbid
she comes over and watches descendants
with me I literally I called her once I
can you please come over and she was
like no you should go to Jack his
apartment cuz Jackie asked me to come
over I'm like no but I'm not going to
Jackie's Jackie needs to come to me but
Jackie's not coming to me to check me to
come to her yeah I called her too I was
like hey I want to come over macho
sentence and she was like you should
call Claudia I'm like Claudia doesn't
watch the session she's just so
independent it's like really [ __ ] you
know it's really frustrating but at
least you have Theo and like yeah we'll
stay at her after
Saturday night I like got my say she
ation of like seeing people and I was
like happy to be in bed and then I
started watching watching love is blind
and I literally didn't get out of bed
from like noon till 10 p.m. yeah I
started love his buying on Saturday
night and then I watched like till 1:00
a.m. then on Sunday I went to brunch
with my friends which was actually
really fun and then I finished [ __ ] in
the afternoon I just couldn't believe I
didn't realize that the shows were
released episodically so I didn't know
like going into it that I was gonna
watch nine hours of a TV show and not
finish it to me I had the opposite
experience where it was like I kept
thinking it was gonna end soon cuz I
knew it was released episode by episode
so I was like we're not gonna get two
weddings and then I was always so
thrilled when there was another episode
yeah it was frustrating honestly and
it's I'm fighting it really difficult
not to let it get spoiled because of
Instagram and the show was filmed two
years ago so people have obviously
posted it and like moved on with their
lives so I'm trying to like stay off but
I've like people in
nation keeps coming to me like my GM's
are flooded with contestants Vanessa
Lachey people who were on the show who
we like never saw like the Rory's of the
world and of course like the one toaster
who goes on and gets engaged like Miss
stories cut yeah right so like my GM's
are flooded with information and I'm
really trying not to open it because I
wanna experience it like just a regular
TV show and I'm so curious like yeah
it's killing me okay well call me George
coz I'm curious Thursday it's going down
I'm so excited
but until then without further ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and drop
all of your sorry before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and that's true and I'm overjoyed to say
something that I felt like I haven't
seen in a while
say you know why she can't even say it
yeah I'm so excited I can't even say it
today's episode ladies and gentleman is
brought to you by Noom getting in shape
doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magic
number on the scale it's about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself so a fitting into your
favorite pair of jeans is your goal
great but there are many reasons you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different and because
we're different Numa just to your
lifestyle they teach you the psychology
behind the decisions you make and then
help you keep track of everything from
workouts and steps to analyzing your
diet and recommending healthy recipes
they connect you personally with a
Sutton assigned goal specialist and a
community of other numers so you have
all the support you need to empower your
change
okay numr if you want to execute better
self-care feel more confident your
clothing have more energy or just
achieve an overall glow Noom just might
be the thing that you need it's a habit
changing solution that helps users learn
to develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses no food is
considered good batter off limits on
noon they teach you moderation and can
be used in conjunction with many
preexisting popular diets if you want it
is not a diet it is an healthy and easy
to stick to a way of life they have one
of the most accurate food databases that
lets you track all your meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance your human if you go
off track there's no shaming there's
just tips to help you get back on track
tomorrow you don't have to change it all
in one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noon
calm / toast that's n oom dot-com /
toast what do you have to lose visit
noon
/ toast to start your trial today that's
n oo m.com / toast
ok numr all monday episode should be
sponsored by noon and i'm yeah a great
call at the first one I was feeling RDH
because I felt like something happened
this weekend that like I needed to talk
about on the toast and I just was
remembering murder the fact that I went
viral on tick-tock Oh
I honestly like I can't even look him in
the face I'm so [ __ ] jealous like I'm
obviously happy for you know that I am
but like I'm so jealous like I worked I
am I take stock and then you just put up
like one [ __ ] video and every video I
put up I work so hard on and then I was
like writing emails on Friday night and
tell me what email you were referring to
anybody don't email where it was like
someone reached out to me and I had to
like connect them with my age and I just
like hated the way it was coming off but
that's what you have to say yeah and I
was writing the email and I was like and
I felt myself my face and I was like oh
that's funny and so I just filmed it and
I actually posted it I felt really
stupid and embarrassed and I was gonna
delete it but instead I went to sleep
and I woke up and I had gone viral and
you've like 400,000 views yeah and like
almost 100,000 likes on it kids can
relate because they were all commenting
like when I email my professor asking
for an extension so I just felt really
see you had a lot of followers I did I
probably got like two thousand five oh
my god I'm green with envy but also
happy for you I learned what happens
when you go viral on tick-tock everyone
lets you know who they think that you
look like oh is what do they say that
illipe nataline pet life with Mac grown
up oh yeah um someone from Midsummer
Night's that movie and they tagged this
girl Ari they said that I look like a
redhead version of her to be honest like
that makes me not want to go viral on
tick-tock like I'm not interested in
hearing who people think I look like
beanie Feldstein Ricki Lake like I'm
just I'm all set like because no one's
gonna tell me what I want to hear like
oh you look like Megan Fox like no one's
gonna say that to me so I'd rather just
stick with my videos that don't go viral
but follow me at girl with no job yeah
so that was a highlight oh also I think
I figured out my coffee situation cuz I
did everything new okay I ordered like
pre-made cold brew
I think the company's called great he's
like I work got it from the supermarket
and it's like a whole brew and then you
mix it with water and milk and so that's
what I drink this morning and it's quite
delicious
so it's [ __ ] nasty water and milk
water milk and and brew disgusting
um what's discussing about this mixing
water and milk makes you want to vomit
with the big thing of brew sickening
okay and you're not you literally make
me sick
nasty nasty I just don't like milk to be
honest it's almond milk so it's not
really like milk and there's like a now
a trend on tick-tock of like kids like
shoving milk down their throat like the
literally little baggies have you seen
that now it's disgusting you would hate
it yeah I mean I don't spend enough
tick-tock time on tick tock for that to
cross my path it's just so unfair like
you don't even spend time I talking to
and viral no but then I was like
checking all weekend I was really
excited about it it's a thrill I didn't
want to make it like a huge deal you
know it is a huge deal yeah I felt like
it was cool no no it's it's empowering
it's wonderful it honestly it's great
for our brand um I just build all over
myself oh but you know what else I was
thinking it was a video that I posted
without makeup and I do look really
young without makeup and I was feeling
like maybe they thought I was one of
them because I wasn't wearing makeup
well have you cracked a case because
I've been wearing like Blazers in mind
that's obviously not the right decision
no we have to look younger except for
the one time I posted it dance without
makeup and everyone's coming darker
[ __ ] ruthless yeah but then but then
some of the tic-tock ors come and defend
you like someone who someone commented
who wears who really wears pajamas like
that I was wearing like you know dramas
cuz I guess kids just wear like old
t-shirts yeah and people were like who
uses those tic toc emojis what do you
have an Android like they were laughing
back at each other and they were they
had my back
honestly that feels good really good
they take it take stalkers Union you
know we're all miss together yeah it was
cool it was really cool okay okay well
let's get into the first story because
speaking of the clap that oh my god I
said I see your iPad and I want to die
at this whole exchange dude I never knew
I needed
Jake Paul Zayn Malik and Gigi Hadid Jake
Paul tweeted um the other night almost
had to clap up Zane from One Direction
bells his name wrong right because he is
a little guy and has an attitude and
basically told me to [ __ ] off for no
reason
when I was being nice to him Zane I know
you're reading this stop being angry cuz
you came home alone to your big-ass
hotel room hahaha Gigi Hadid wrote back
lol cuz he doesn't care to hang with you
and your embarrassing crew of YouTube
groupies home alone with his best
friend's like a respectful King because
he has me Sui
unbothered by your irrelevant ugly ass
go to bed okay I mean there's so many
elements that we must break to out I
think first and foremost the fact that
gigi hadid responded to Jake Paul
calling him an irrelevant ugly when we
have famously been called irrelevant
uglies by the BTS Stan hood which by the
way we're not coming for you so just
like we love you and appreciate you and
please thank you for that beautiful
inside but just don't be stowed upon us
don't come for us again like Uyghur she
can't handle I thought it was exciting
oh my god I wanted to die they were just
referring to us as a black-haired girl
and the red-haired girl
so that's what's first and foremost
notable here the second notable thing is
I have like a thing with girls women
females who refer to their heterosexual
partners as kings like it is one of my
least favorite I think it's the lose
aureus thing and they were actually
unloved as blind someone referred I want
to say it was Dimond yeah when they had
the Hat that said when he had the hat
that said daddy daddy and then they were
like would you wear one that says this
or that yeah and she was like you're my
king like I just I think it's so first
of all it's like this is 2020 like that
is such an antiquated like you're my
king like I work for you know like
that's just not a thing
and it's also just so cringy like my
husband is my king like I would never
[ __ ] say that when I read that part
like they're respectful king that he is
ruined I just know yeah also I do agree
I didn't really feel like this warranted
a response from Gigi like Jake Paul is
known for being like a digital menace
like I don't think anyone was taking his
tweet seriously you know what um after
she wrote that he managed em he deleted
his initial tweet and he said like no
one should let me tweet when I'm drunk
so like she shut it down I feel like if
she hadn't tweeted we would have been
like Oh Satan is an [ __ ] like telling
him to [ __ ] off for no reason I am 100%
Cera's Dane told him to [ __ ] off but I'm
sure Jake Paul was being an annoying
loser like yeah I don't know why Jake
Paul things set like him and Zane would
ever hang out hanging out and I'm sure
they've been in the same place at the
same time so I didn't find it so weird
that they had like interacted but I just
felt like this exchange was literally so
unnecessary from everyone like it was so
unnecessary for Jake to come for Zane
and then it was even more unnecessary
for the biggest supermodel in the world
to defend her [ __ ] boyfriend to a
youtuber like yeah
what this is a parallel universe it's a
parallel universe and the response was
just so cringy like I had to oh I liked
most of it the part where she calls his
crew embarrassing crew of YouTube
groupies yeah no but that just felt like
a reminder of why she shouldn't be
tweeting at right right but and where
was just like now I need more details on
the interaction feel like it was at in
Milan or wherever Fashion Week is
currently taking place yeah yeah yeah
also we never actually formally even
reported on this show that Gigi and
saying are back together right I mean I
think their OTP and their end game and
so like they should stop like hurting
people like Tyler see with their
nonsense Joe Jonas totally yeah I don't
um
I don't necessarily ship them cuz I
actually think she's too good for him
but I think in a lot of ways like she's
obsessed with him and like yeah I have
no choice but to respect that and when
they showed up at the Met Gala um
looking like robots like her nails
everyone was dying over them like I
thought that was their peak and the fact
that they just like fell apart right
after that like I never really
understood I feel like their
relationship is super toxic but I don't
know why I feel that way yeah I think
that it is too but I just think there's
so many elements like their books so
famous and it's just I'm sure it's
intense but I think that they're meant
to be together and they'll find their
way to make it work they might break up
and get back together again in their
like and again and again but I I think
they're each other's person they remind
me of like Jessica and Mark know each
other's person don't know but like she
Gigi works and like what does they do
literally all day I don't know but like
I'm sure he's in the studio with his
friends like like making yeah no I'm
kidding about laying down I do I do
agree that they're Opie I just for some
reason um feel like it's a toxic
situation yeah I mean you don't keep
breaking up and getting back together if
it's if it's like healthy yeah cool
okay what a weird like turn of events
you know from Milan Fashion Week is just
digital creator central Dixie uh Charlie
Jame Leo's there every [ __ ] like
teenager is there except for us yeah but
that's okay we like being here
yeah no please don't invite me to Milan
Fashion Week I actually would not want
to go yeah like I don't want to be in
Milan first of all like there's like I
just feel like I'm not really into
Europe like I'm not into like the super
small food portions and like the lack of
air conditioning and just like the vibe
like I'm very American like I love like
big leather couches you
like that tiny little furniture like I
love the American Way of life and I
never want to be invited to Paris or a
Milan Fashion Week like I'll be invited
anyone wants invite me to New York
Fashion Week like they have air
conditioning that I can [ __ ] with but I
just don't like Europe okay and like I
can't deal like when I met with people I
can't having conversations like oh my
god you know Venice in the spring I just
you know it's amazing in the spring my
bedroom you know like I'm just the
opposite I've like people who go to
Milan Fashion Week so I'm actually not
jealous you know what's amazing in the
spring see oh no no no - my year-round
CEO and you know where Theo is home and
you know it's actually one of my
favorite times of year
Theo Fashion Week it's like all the
newest trends in fishermen out
everywhere it's it's cool cuz like for
the first few years of the festival I
like wasn't invited but now I feel like
I'm kind of a mainstay at Theo Fashion
Week and it feels really special
yeah TFW like doesn't get better than
the sponsored by mercedes-benz yeah
remember when Fashion Week was M BFW
mercedes-benz Fashion Week and it wasn't
NY FW in the early days of like bloggers
interesante but it sounds familiar
yeah it was all at Lincoln Center yeah
that was weird mm-hmm okay well next
story is a little devastating and
heartbreaking Skeet Ulrich and Marisol
Nichols who play a few Jones and
Hermione Lodge are leaving Riverdale
did it seem like they walked away or
they were written out I have I can't
imagine that they were written out
because they're so integral to the plot
like they're great actors but they each
released statements to TVLine skete
saying I'm incredibly grateful for the
friendships I've made on Riverdale and I
will miss seeing everyone on a daily
basis I'm proud to have been part of
such a talented group of people in front
of the camera and behind but I've
decided that it's time for me to move on
to explore other creative opportunities
it's just weird if he really did decide
to like resign it's strange that it
would be at the same time as Marisol
yeah maybe they're just you know I the
cast also in the show are graduating
things are changing maybe they felt like
this is a good time for them to do some
turnover he's also set to co-star in the
upcoming Tom Hanks film BIOS and the
kwibi series free raeshawn oh he'll be
fine and then Marisol
nickels said part of life in Riverdale
and part of growing up is saying goodbye
to people
I'm grateful - oh that's what writer
Ross said I'm sorry he said I'm grateful
to skeet and Marysol for their
incredible work on the show these last
four years I mean wish them all well on
their future endeavors you know what to
be honest I'm actually really glad about
this even though I don't watch Riverdale
I started to get over it when it became
less about the core for like I love the
high school drama and then it was not
about that it was not like running for
mayor like and so much of the parents
and what is Hyrum doing like I found
that parents drama to be so boring and
that's part of the reason why I like God
over the show so if it's now taking a
direction of like back to being about
the kids I could deal with that because
I just want more like Reggie drama you
know yeah I feel like I could see the
show without Hermione lodge but f/p
Jones is really like the moral compass
of the show he's the sheriff he's always
like failing Sheriff yeah he's the
sheriff these days he's bailing the kids
out of trouble
how the [ __ ] do you go from being like a
leader of a gang to the sheriff the show
is so unknown said you get you a man who
could you both okay and it's great
because now when there's a problem they
call the police oh that is good it's
really great for Pilate himself oh my
brother that show was just giving me so
many ulcers like watching these kids
make such poor decisions yeah just call
the cop this new season is fabulous I
haven't watched since the winter break
because I like to watch them all
together but it's been fabulous I don't
really plan on like ever committing a
crime but after all the shows and movies
that I've watched about like you know
murder and whatever I've come to learn
that it's always the cover-up and it's
never the crime like I just not that I
plan on murdering anyone but if I do
like I'm calling the police
like was probably an accident I'm not a
murderer I'm glad to hear that yeah it's
like you know even the affair like they
were on a dark windy Hamptons Road like
yes they were drinking but like I just
felt like when they killed Scott
Lockhart like call the play call the
police yeah and he was attacking that
girl oh yeah and he was attacking
Allison and yes Helen had had like a
beer but they could have said that it
was Noah if they called the police
initially then Noah was like a
hit-and-run er yeah even though wasn't
even him you know like exactly precise
always the cover-up never the crime
okay well Rihanna delivered a powerful
speech at the n-double-a-cp
Image Awards this weekend okay
showed up she is the snapshot I'm
looking so beautiful she why with these
Awards on a Saturday night was it on
Saturday yeah and I couldn't like keep
up with it because I was having a drink
that's all of our shows should be on
every night except for Friday or
Saturday I could even go for an award
show on a weeknight like of course my
Monday nights are available on the
bachelor CMAs are on like a Wednesday
yeah I'm I I'm into that yeah the CMAs
are anyone's yeah I think it's totally
fine they don't need to go up to our
Sunday nights like Sunday nights are
stressful enough agreed with me too much
of for our Awards so I just found out
about like all the the moments from the
n-double-a-cp Awards afterwards which is
just annoying
I found them out like this morning last
night but Rihanna received the
President's Award for her philanthropy
work at the n-double-a-cp Image Awards
in Pasadena California the star who wore
a purple chiffon she hot Couture for the
event sickening was particularly honored
for her fundraising efforts with various
charities including raising Malawi
UNICEF and Claro
Lionel foundation the nonprofit
organization she founded in honor of her
grandparents
devoted to emergency preparedness like I
didn't even know all this stuff about
Rihanna
she's she's so dynamic you know there's
so many different sides to her there's
music
Rihanna there's fashioned Rihanna
there's beauty there's philanthropic
Rihanna she's everything of the sort and
now like everyone's clipping her speech
and like posting on their instagrams
which I'm loving this is so unrelated
and I want to get back to Rihanna but
did you see and is it a story
all that weird Haley Bieber Justin
Bieber Cara Delevingne Instagram drama
oh no I meant to make it a story but we
have a Justin Bieber story so we'll talk
about a it's so strange yeah I came back
to Rihanna like I'm so glad she's
leaving her house again and I just like
where's music please don't them honestly
Rihanna please don't stop the music
give me my single cam ready I have a
message for Rihanna please don't stop
the music music music thank you I don't
think we're ever getting more music
she's so happy and so grateful like she
don't need to make another album like
literally till only if it was like it
was getting like the only reason she
would ever release another album was
like if she wanted to and I don't even
get the vibe that she wants to know she
I don't think she's so hard I don't
think she wants to take on like another
project and I have to respect that
yeah and I feel like if I hadn't known
that ant I was the last album we were
gonna get for her like I would have
given it more of my
I go onto the tour in Barclays Center
that was one of the major regrets of my
life was not going to the life of Pablo
at Madison Square Garden I had asked Ben
to get me tickets for like a Valentine's
Day and he didn't get it and then you
ended up going and like it was literally
my favorite album and I'm sitting in bed
watching your stories being like why the
[ __ ] am I not here and I got really mad
at bed actually
and also not seeing me on at Barclays
center yeah I think I think that's fair
I would love to see like Rihanna do
Coachella or something
yeah I feel like cuz you don't have to
be promoting new music in order to do
Coachella I just did a Rihanna soul
cycle ride oh that's good fabulous it
was my hundredth soul cycle ride did you
see that I did see that on your
Instagram actually done more than 100
but I've used so many accounts over
riders because I've been doing it since
high school so this is the account that
I've been using since 2017 um so it's
100 rides in oh wow I was about to say
two years in three year and what do they
bring you oh they had they had a little
sign at the front desk and then they had
a card on my bike with like a sweet note
oh that's cute
and then I got to like make a wish
sharing the ride like if it's your
birthday they bring you a candle and it
was just it was nice it was low-key I
didn't want like a whole thing yeah you
know I never on cheering for me like no
good yeah yeah yes sir it's terrible but
it was great it was exciting um anyways
laughing I've acted like so you've
turned a hundred plus so huh glows I can
count on one hand I know that you had I
did one ride for like a Jordin Sparks
event that I got invited to what I
thought Jordin Sparks was gonna be there
and she wasn't I did my first SoulCycle
ever and like I remember in high school
you did a musical Monday with me yes I
remember one time going to a random one
on 63rd Street and they played honey I'm
good by Andy Grammer and I actually had
a good time
oh the toast cycle or the gift of life
charitable I actually think that's
something then one other one with me do
I make you ever do like a Taylor Swift
One or something no you always like try
to make me but I think that you and I
went I took a picture oh that was
musical Monday yeah no I've literally
done five souls i Girls Club and I truly
don't plan on going to that secondhand
anytime soon I think that you should do
like a Taylor Swift ride with by the way
I have said many times about soul cycle
and until someone hears my cry like I
will not go back I like the environment
like I like the music i like that it's
too short
it's 40 minutes like I can get with that
I like to vibe but the seed is something
I just can't handle and my ass literally
might literally do it not to get
graphically the
inside of my ass cheeks like are
literally sore still from my lessels
like I understand but like hundreds of
thousands of people do SoulCycle and yes
the first time you do it it hurts but
then it's fine but I just don't
understand why they have like a like a
penis shape to see it I mean like why
can't I just get like a nice round see
it and even the cushions like they don't
even help I actually think they make it
worse I agree with that they don't help
so I just until they get a special bike
for me with like a nice normal seat I
don't think I can go back maybe you
should bring your own seat yeah I would
love to get like a big pillow what does
this eat like on a peloton probably this
thing see peloton you miss out on all
the things I actually do like about soul
cycle like the camaraderie the screaming
the cheering the singing the darkened
darkness yeah yeah so I don't need to be
like screaming in the middle of my house
I do that already you know yeah okay
next story just brought you speaking of
bettering I don't know this is the
segment's brought to you by function of
beauty oh and by the way Kim Kardashian
uses function of beauty oh yes you see
if you needed another reason to go and
get some we all know the frustration
bottles and bottles and half use
shampoos and conditioners piled up in
your bathroom each one promising to be
everything your hair has ever needed but
they lied to you somebody lied to you
you deserve better
so try function of beauty there the
Internet's top-rated customized hair
care brand with over 30,000 five-star
customer reviews and Counting whether
you have curly or straight naturally
processed hair function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your unique hair type style
preference and hair goals to begin the
short four question quiz and save 20%
off on your first purchase go to
function of beauty calm / toast tell
them about your hair even customize your
formula with fragrance or color or you
can go die in fragrance free the
products are so personalized your name
is even printed on the bottle plus
function and beauty is vegan and
cruelty-free they never use sulfates
parabens flat elates minerals oil
mineral oils or any other harmful
ingredients so get started go to
function of beauty.com / toast to take
your 4 part hair profile quiz and save
20% off your first order don't spend
another minute in hair misery go to
function of beauty.com / toast to let
them know that we sent you that's
function of beauty.com / toast you get
20% off your first order and maybe just
maybe you wake up looking like Kim
Kardashian maybe just maybe I feel like
everyone's always asking Theo what he
used
is on his consulate and he uses function
beating yeah he's actually thank you for
like spoiling but he's actually becoming
the face a function of beauty which is a
laughs really exciting really or is he
becoming the botch
I don't know what you're gonna say yeah
sorry I totally misspoke see I was like
they're actually I probably an email
from function of beauty right now like
coming for me for life yeah yeah watch
sorry okay Justin Bieber sings Marvin
saps never would have made it at Kanye
West Sunday service yes I saw they love
to have a pop star at Sunday service and
I love that SIA is like truly my number
one but they invited Justin Bieber he's
very religious I thought it was like a
great on brand collab totally he sounded
amazing okay I don't know if I would say
amazing what do you mean he has a great
voice yeah yeah so I just thought he
could have done better
did you see they were also seeing that
tic tac toe song what song well they
changed all the words we that's
interesting because you know what Margo
told me about that song it's called the
box and that song is the song that went
so viral that it actually was number one
on Billboard and stopped yummy from
going number one like in Justin Bieber
now this like whole social media
campaign to get young me to number one
and the box which is the tick tock song
I became so big that it actually outdid
yummy Wow mother I love it song Kupala
2412 boots but there are the bells at
the back by the way it was actually a
great Sunday service I watched all of
Kim's stories yeah and it was just so
great she had a lot of north dancing and
I'm so obsessed with North you've seen
the video of her original song at her
school four corners oh my god
iconic iconic I love it so much I'm so
excited for when she's old enough to
like do her own thing have her Instagram
yeah and we can like hear the original
song she's making with Kanye um really
quickly back to tick tock music last
weekend I was in Miami obviously and I
went like a million clubs and I think
it's fascinating how songs on tick-tock
are literally taking over the world like
in clubs they played the Box a million
times they played when a lose control la
la like Tiesto played both of those
songs like I just think tick tock is
having an actual influence on the music
industry I love it I love it we need to
get toast like
I want a Kentuckian someone come up with
a toast challenge yeah I mean I think
here are the ones who should come up
with it that's sad
we need to come up with the dance I'll
show you we need a nation to Paulo to
come and say hello and to make up a
dance for us I agree
okay so while we're talking about Justin
Bieber him and Cara Delevingne
so when he was on spill your guts are
fill your guts which is best show and
the best segment James Corden asked him
to rank his wife Haley's friends
Kendall Gigi and Cara Delevingne like
from favorite like from one two three
and he had Kendall at number one because
he spent a bunch of time with her and
then he had Gigi and Cara but he just
did it in order of people he spent a lot
of time with right it wasn't she wasn't
shady at all but then Cara Delevingne
posted her Instagram and posted also
some photos of her and Justin in the
past and then when he performed at the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show and was
hugged boggling her down the runway and
he was like 12 like come on yeah and and
she was just like if there's no beef why
do you have me blocked right that which
is beard so but I think that's only
reason she posted that because he's out
here blocking her but then also saying
they have no beef and I have to assume
that he blocked her when she posted in
support of Taylor Swift against Scooter
Braun because Justin Bieber like is
Scooter Braun they're one person oh I
guess so but I feel like even if okay so
there's beef he blocked her but like he
was trying to be mature about it yeah
and not air their beef out on national
television so I kind of like I thought
it was so unnecessary I thought it was
unnecessary and by the way I have
recently become like an Ashley Benson
Cara Delevingne like groupie like I an
apologist but I don't agree with that
whatsoever like that was seems like
Thursday's like a pop culture fan like I
loved the tea but just as two people who
are friends or foes it's just like that
was it's necessary and obviously it look
that's like painful for Haley yeah look
she's the one in the middle so awkward
like I feel bad first though she's
always in that position they her life is
just out here like defending her
relationship defending her man and
there's a lot of benefits to being mrs.
Bieber but there's definitely a lot of
like troubles that come with it and
honestly it seems like it sucks like
people are always coming for them like
in in different shapes of forms that I
think she feels like in a lot of way
she's like a publicist for Justin
because she's like the vessel in which
yes she's always like commenting
on Instagram posts like clearing things
up yeah always about Selena always
always honestly Nokomis banika of course
terrible have you been watching their
YouTube show no but um I saw that they
released an episode about the wedding
which was essentially just like their
wedding video and of course I watched it
and I thought it was beautiful and I
just I think that I'm gonna say
something crazy like I think Haley
Bieber is the most beautiful woman in
the world
Wow look I think that if I were to have
a style like goal it would be her well I
think she is so stylish
she is the snatchler for every occasion
she's always dressed to the nines even
for like even when she's low-key and
wearing sweats like they left the spa
yeah in California the other day and
like she was wearing sweats but it was
styled no no she's perfectly styled for
every occasion and I didn't look at the
interviews on the seasons show which I
don't like the name seasons um she's
looking stylin while in livin' it up in
the city yeah no I love I love that and
I thought the wedding video was really
cute really special I loved like seeing
all the celebrities that were there I
really didn't realize like how super
super close he was but like most of the
Kardashian it's like Kylie kendall Kris
because of Cory
and I thought that was really cool and I
love that Kylie was in the video like
multiple times oh yeah she was like in
it multiple times and the ceremony was
actually really really small and Kylie
and Kendall we're both they're like
they're really good friends I love that
I love that because they're so close
with hailey
no I think it's I think it's the Jaden
Smith of it all he was there too and I
just think they used to be like a crew I
think Kendall is definitely there with
Hailey but I think that Kris and Kylie
are there for Justin Kendall is okay
okay cool
yeah and they had like Scooter Braun
talking about like how remarkable of a
woman hailey was I loved and then you
got to see just like her being beautiful
which is my favorite and I just um
there's so many things about their
relationship that I really like and I
just love her but some hair believe her
I'm a belieber excuse me but like
Justine oh and then they decided to like
have him sing one less lonely girl to
her like on the whim at the end of the
wedding which is really cute she was
like I was literally living my dream and
it was really cute but like something
that Justin seems off to me yeah I think
everyone can agree okay I don't know if
we can really put our finger on it
yeah they'll say that he's no longer
doing that he used to you know Jenny
talks about it a lot us right so what
makes you think that now he's not yeah
and he has Lyme disease oh he does yeah
so he says I believe so
Wow sure though it's tough times okay
biz and final story this one's for you
friends reading special oh my god they
don't even call it that I know but I
don't no one's pretending like it's
something out it's no no really because
all the promotion was pretending like it
was pretending that it was a reboot okay
yeah right
and by the way it's a reunion I know
it's like you know when they intent when
they're watching Cheers
and they have the reunion yeah hey like
this is like a DVD extra of my friends
who like love friends but aren't really
like involved in pop culture we went to
dinner on Saturday and they were like so
excited to go to dinner so house and
they were like so excited about the
reboot and I was like I had to break it
to them because they don't they just
read the headlines my god right I'm like
it's like a BTS interview like it's not
like a one-hour thing yeah it's so
misleading and all of the press like all
of them posting on Instagram at the same
time it's happening they know what they
thought everyone would think you know
what I mean so obviously I'm happy I'm
excited whatever but like let's let's
just be more specific with the branding
okay but I do think it's not would you
even want to reboot no I think that
reboots ruins stuff I agree and now
you'll get a show that talks about your
the thing that you love with the people
that you love and I think you're
actually gonna love it by the way for
sure all I want is like for the friends
cast to acknowledge that they were on
friends like they're all pretend like
they weren't so I am obviously excited
but I just think that the branding the
marketing of this reunion special was
kind of misleading to fans who do want a
special but I think that friends is so
special because reboots like disgrace
the sanctity of a show like no reboot
has ever made the show better like
honestly I think there were the Connors
like the Roseanne reboot is a joke I
think that fuller house is I considered
one of the most successful reboots and
it's just it's not a reboot half the
cast isn't on it it's just DJ and
Stephanie that's a different show there
are so many reboots like Girl Meets
World
Ravens home even Gilmore Girls which
people were so excited about wasn't very
popular to 100 wrested development the
new season that was on Netflix terrible
reboot that was just Netflix continuing
it like after ten years that's what
every bit is oh I don't know reboots
like a new cast and stuff like is it
premise if it's the same cast but
they're like older then isn't it just
like season 10 no no it's considered
okay well the unscripted reunion special
will feature all the stars as well as
series creators David Crane and Marta
Kauffman sources tell The Hollywood
Reporter that the cast who all
negotiated together will earn more than
double their former per episode fee from
the Union and be paid between 2.5
million dollars and three million
dollars for the special right because
it's famously renegotiate their salaries
together during the show's original run
to earn a then historic $1,000,000 per
episode wait that's so crazy I love that
thing to go shaded it together because
there's power in numbers and I think
that like not one person is not getting
paid more than the other right now I
know you could see how that was a
problem on Big Bang Theory where there
was like two tiers of casts like mine be
all like was unlike the lower tier who
was are obsessed with me yeah I swear to
God
if you go through every episode of the
place you have found a way better one
because I watched a terrible Lifetime
movie because honestly she's one of the
only people whose names I know from that
show I think I'm just like saying but
they were the kaley cuoco x' and the
mines and they make different salaries
and then like the higher tier like
boycotted on behalf of the lower tier
it's problematic like a an ensemble show
needs to be a band of like family um I
mean I didn't watch Big Bang Theory so I
can't speak to tier 1 in here too but
some of the shows that I know and love
like there is a tier 1 and tier 2 and
tier 1 should be getting paid more well
yeah if they're like a main character
and also like I'm thinking of Modern
Family now because they just film their
last episode yeah and I do think like
the adult should be paid more than the
kids well so that's how it was for the
majority of the beginning of the show
but then the kids became adults right so
then the kids we negotiated but the kids
were still making less than the adults
that's fair I don't know why but I just
do yeah I think like the person who
seems most interesting in their ages
Sarah Hyland because she started out as
like a child actor yeah but like a
teenager it really became an adult on
screen but like then she is she making
the same as like Sofia Vergara
know what no no no she's not but is she
making the same as like Luke her brother
shouldn't be right that's what I'm
saying that's that's a huge ensemble
cast and they all play such a different
role I wouldn't consider them all main
characters and we consider the parents
the main character yes but I think Manny
should be paid like at least yes and
Lily should be paid the least she's the
most [ __ ] annoying character like I
think she almost ruined the show for me
I actually stopped watching she that's
so nice she got too old and she was
talking so much it's like just shut up
she really it's there's a certain type
of TV show where a kid is a certain age
it's very specific and they grow up on
TV show and you happen to be seeing them
at their ugliest ears you mean bran
stark and it's like you have no choice
but to hate them because they're so ugly
but it's like some it's just you know
it's just luck that sometimes people
grow up in their view and they really
lost them like Arielle winter winter but
she was older that's something it's a
specific age I think it's like if you
start if you're on a TV show at like the
age of five like how old it was brand I
don't know how old kids are it's hard
for me to gauge like based on how they
look but there's something like you
catch them kids like for a very short
even the most beautiful kids like even
Cindy Crawford when they're growing up
they hit a certain age and they get ugly
for a little bit stop Huberty
no it's pre-puberty like brat like
there's just something happens and so
I'm glad I was never a child actor
because like I had a very ugly stage
like everyone does so certain kids like
just get it at the worst time and it's
based on when they become famous bran
lilly lilly grew out of it but there was
a couple seasons where she was really
[ __ ] annoying looking okay even the
most beautiful kid it's it's kids become
like gross looking you know no I don't
know you don't agree no and they see
where you two have kids because I don't
want to like to see them through that
ugly stage yeah there's sorry there is
an ugly stage of kids I feel like I
didn't have an ugly stage into like two
years no I had like a sickening stunning
stage followed by like a behemoth stage
[Laughter]
that's what I'm saying and Lily is proof
of that
don't make her know her character was so
annoying like and they just maybe it's
not her fault like they just gave her
the worst
the Olsen twins never went through the
awkward teen years thank you so I do
think it's like it's possible not to but
a lot of kids do but it's also possible
not to yeah but most kids do the Olsen
twins are like remarkably exceptional
you know yeah I would anyway I just
wouldn't compare myself to them ever has
Evan the fact that we look so much alike
you know okay I've been dying to talk
about love is blind I just think we have
to get into the recap do you have
anything else you need to say I have to
get into the recap no nothing else
matters have everyone love is fine right
now
your love is wine recap is brought to
you by third love they do bras
differently they believe that every
woman deserves to feel comfortable and
confident every day except for Jessica
from love as no kidding
with the record I love is blend that's
good with the right kind of support
they'll help every woman do this their
bras are designed to fit you not the
other way around
they're designed with measurements from
millions of women their bra styles are
made to fit your life
with over 80 bra sizes you know that the
only one that matters is yours
third love makes bras that you believe
in every bra is backed by their perfect
fit promise and you have 60 days to wash
it and wear it if you don't love it
returns are always free take their fit
finder quiz answer a few simple
questions to find your perfect fit in 60
seconds over 15 million women have taken
the quiz to date did you know that your
breast shape matters when finding a good
fit I have a bell shape if anyone's
wondering and they have the perfect fit
promise every customer 60 days to wear
the bra wear the bra washi I put it to
the test if you don't love it you have a
free return and third level wash it and
donate it to a woman in need so you can
feel good knowing that third love is
doing good on your behalf they have a
team of expert fit stylists they're
dedicated to helping you find your
perfect fit and they're always available
to chat via email returns and exchanges
are always easy there bras are
comfortable I've been wearing the
t-shirt bras since they started
sponsoring the show it has changed my
life and my back third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering our listeners
15% off your first order go to 3rd
love.com slash morning toast now to find
your perfect fitting bra and get 15% off
your first purchase that's a third
love.com
slash morning toast for 15% off today
thank you a third love is blind for
sponsoring the most important segment
we're ever gonna do love is blind new
reality show on FX
if you haven't watched it it's being
released episodically which is not
something Netflix usually does usually
they okay there's only one episode left
I think it took a while for it to game
seen some
people had watched it and they were
batch releasing episodes like it wasn't
one at a time so if you haven't watched
it you don't want to spoil it
you can watch now in the next the finale
airs on Thursday yeah so okay first of
all I'm just I'm upset I'm obsessed I
didn't expect to fall in love with the
concept so much from the minute the show
started they got right to it know Chris
Harrison like [ __ ] Vanessa a Nick
Lachey are in and out they're in the
show like four times literally I love
them I think they were perfect for it
like I love a married stable couple even
though like the drama with Jessica
Simpson like I'll survive they got right
into it and I loved that and it was
clean like I felt like the people there
even though like they didn't have their
phones they want people to focus like
whatever I feel like those people were
actually having a good time like the
girls became friends from what we've
read now about behind the scenes so
apparently we see the journey of six
engaged couples apparently eight couples
got engaged
including the therapist on set Rory yes
just the unsung hero giving everyone
premium advice it was just weird that he
was in the show so much for not ever
ever having had a connection yeah so uh
the show started with like about fifty
singles and dirty
no no they started with fifty and they
kept whittling it down um because they
didn't know like who was gonna connect
and so you got to say like who you
enjoyed spending time with and they then
you spend more and more time with them
to the point then it's a free-for-all
and you can spend all night with someone
and they don't even film you at that
point see that was cool they really are
interested in people getting to know
each other I think what I liked about
the show was that the experiment and the
success of the experiment was the
priority not making good TV like I don't
feel like they forced a lot of stuff I
think the the priority was to see
whether or not this type of experiment
would work like and they put a lot of
effort and resources into putting them
in the controlled environment and making
them you know introduced and and and
putting them back in real life in a very
real way like I thought they did a good
job of really testing this hypothesis
like his love life and it wasn't just
like a dumb react towards the end it got
dumber and dumber but I think in the
beginning I was really like believe that
and it's like the wedding I didn't
realize that they had up until they like
the wedding wasn't like do you take this
man this woman it's like do you say yes
to this wedding in general that's when
you either turn and run like yeah I
didn't know that that's what we I
thought you could break up at any time
but it's like I guess they wouldn't pass
up the opportunity to be on camera
marking Jessica like of
they should've broken [ __ ] Mexico
Jessica is the whoa whenever when they
were in the pods like people were
connecting with her like I just don't
understand how oh I got it like honestly
her voice her baby voice was so annoying
but I kind of liked her in the beginning
I thought like it was I didn't
understand how she could be so pretty
so successful and really be at 34 have
so much trouble finding love and then I
got to know her and I totally understood
why no I obviously um has a drinking
problem oh yes okay so let's have met
our favorite couples cuz obviously
Lauren and Cameron are the fan favorites
and they are everything of the sort and
they got me from the very beginning like
this second when she was like I think I
love you and he was just like I love you
I was like you do know and they're the
definition of love is blind me right
they're the only one who filled face
actual like adversity and challenges in
the real world really but everyone just
cos a he/she beggin somebody's dying for
a challenge she's like she's waiting for
one person to say something that so that
she has an excuse to walk away Jackie
totally but someone in the the choices
bind Facebook group is literally the
most amazing place I present all night
and someone made a really good point
because the concept of the show was like
is love is blind that can you fall in
love with someone's emotional connection
and then like see what they look like
and maybe not like be physically
attracted to them when they chose like
an above average group an above average
good-looking group like no one and there
was Abby's like I don't really feel like
you could consider love is bind when
like at the end of the day there's no
safety net of knowing the person behind
that door is like you you know like when
there was like 15 people girls and guys
like there were some not cute people
yeah that's true but you know yeah yeah
I just felt like it would have been
really interesting oh you guys know
right and then like you know someone
with like a facial deformity you know
what I mean like I just think that love
I mean and then it would have been like
an awful show like someone would have
been putting just like a bad position to
look like an [ __ ] yeah like honestly
diamond like she was like she got
injustice justice for diamond like that
was not that was something that should
have been shared in the positive feeling
Adiemus the you know they're opening up
they're talking about their lives and
that's a big part of your life that
you're not sharing so like you can't get
engaged to someone without knowing
everything about that also don't you
feel like it would have been easier if
you had something that like it seemed
like he had a lot of shame around his
sexuality
so if you have something you're nervous
to tell someone about wouldn't it be
easier to tell it to them in a pod then
it would be like in Mexico yeah so I
didn't understand that first of all like
I didn't really think that their
relationship had longevity like I didn't
see the spark I didn't hear it with
certain couples like I felt like with
Lauren and Cameron I was like it's there
like I totally got it and with them I
didn't see it but I was like proud of
them for for taking on this journey and
you knowing that there was that like
truth bomb waiting for them like you
knew they were never gonna work out but
I did not expect that conversation to go
so poorly like I'm at Carlton's and dick
he's such a dick she was like being very
thoughtful and taking her time and being
honest you know and he just he just
flipped and made it about something that
it wasn't right so he has he considered
labels himself bisexual he's a male and
a female many women in the past and he
didn't tell her that and of course like
that's something you have to tell
someone that's not something that not
everyone is gonna be comfortable with
and then like the second she didn't have
the reaction I was like oh it's fine
like the second she that just brush it
off he calls her ignorant he sent her
wig was slipping like I was tired that
was so [ __ ] rude that conference I
mean that fight was hilarious but he's a
dick he was so mean and I feel for her
because she got like robbed of this
experience totally because like you
don't get engaged to someone without
knowing as much as you possibly can just
by talking I feel like the show had a
lot like had a good success rate I don't
know what ends up happening but I think
it set itself up for a good chance of
succeeding because of the crop of people
they chose like they found people of
like 10 to 15 years apart who were all
really really looking for marriage and I
feel like that's the problem with the
bachelor it's like the formula of the
show is starting to self-employed where
people know they can get successful and
it's hard to find people who are really
just genuinely looking for love and I
think they did a really good job of
casting the show because as much as
their thirst monsters now we see it all
like everyone like Giannina like
everyone's Instagram it's thirsty
thirsty thirsty but I really felt like
when the show was filmed in 2018 like
these people were genuinely like open to
finding love in an experiment yes but
then I think what we're when a little
sideways is it's clearly not working
with some of these couples and if they
weren't being filmed they would have
just walked away like two of the engaged
couples I know wanna Rory did an
interview where he said he got engaged
he didn't they didn't continue on his
journey
because the production actually wasn't
didn't expect the show to work so well
they didn't have like the resources to
follow eight engage couples so they
whittled it down to six so him and his
fiance went to Miami and did their own
honeymoon but eventually they broke up
but if they were in this situation they
would have held on longer like I'm sorry
but well I can't remember anyone's name
oh I actually was thinking how I can
remember everyone única and Mark and you
know what's really interesting is two of
the guys Damian's name is Matt because
at the altar he said Matthew Damien
powers oh and Barnett's name Barnett's
name is Matt so I think that no sorry
Damien's name is mark okay so they
didn't give mark they did want there to
be two marks okay so they called him
Damien and there must have been another
guy named Matt which is why they started
calling Barnett Barnett got it well you
can remember anyone's names but their
two couples
oh I mean Jessica and Mark like she was
not into him the minute they got to
Mexico and it's like she was not even
into him in the pods okay because he's
short of course just say it she said it
once and then that's all you needed to
know because also but like he was likes
it in ways when she was when she was
talking to him the first night in Mexico
on the bed and like it was the first
time we heard her say that he's littler
than and I didn't know that he was short
because I didn't like him she was
sitting on the ground all the time but
then when he was like laying on the
couch with his leg up like looks so
small dude like you're not helping
yourself I firmly believe and I feel
like the show does a really good job of
showing how like you can get to know
someone without knowing what they look
like and then once you like fall in love
with them you will become more attracted
to them like I firmly believe that like
people become attractive to you based on
who they are I agree but I think it I
think that love can be blind but I think
that they're sometimes not enough
some people who are who rely too heavily
on looks or are just shallow and love
therefore is not blind right so I think
it can be and I think the experiment
proved that in a lot of ways that like
really getting to know someone whether
or not maybe you would have met them in
another circumstance and would have
written them off and not thought that
they were cute but I think getting to
know someone makes them more physically
attractive to you 100% but I don't think
that was the case for Jessica and Mark
because I don't think they really ever
had like that big of a connection she
was running off tomorrow you know what
it's like when I actually watched them
in the pods I thought that that was it
but then when you she's explaining their
connection
his mom and it's like we're both from
Chicago and love the Bears and have labs
okay that's a strange coincidence it was
that not a connection like those and
that's what they kept relying on oh and
even when he said the part about his
tattoo and Christianity and his kids I
thought that was really touching but
again being of the same religion okay so
a Christian Chicago going dog lover so
that's not she there's a million you
know I didn't think that I think that
they both I think he definitely like had
a crush on her and like liked her a lot
I'm not doubting his feelings I think
that she like I really wanted the
experiment to work and be really one
that should just be on TV so well when I
was watching and I was like wow mark is
just one of those guys who knows what he
wants and he's gonna wait around and
stick it out until she realizes that
he's a guy what he doesn't realize is
that like she'll never come to that
conclusion
but then when I was in the love is the
toast is buying Facebook group um it's
clear that mark is athirst monster yeah
and he's here to promote his fitness
business and now watching through that
lens it's like oh no he's not you know
he's not sure of this love and gonna
make it work he just wants to stay on TV
see but I don't think it's fair to now
watch through that lens because honestly
like if you're not taking advantage of
this opportunity like I think that's
silly
and I feel like he didn't do anything
that made me feel like he had bad
intentions watching him like I really
felt like if anything he was just guilty
of being dumb and blind because he
couldn't see that like Jessica wanted
nothing to do with him like I just I
think he was guilty of that I don't
think it's fair to watch through the
lens because I love Janina like she's
one of my favorite people from the show
and she's a thirstiness of them all have
you seen her Instagram she's like a full
time content creator yes so I was Lauren
but I don't know I just the women one
it's different and two that's her job
and she's making the most of it but like
it's just different from the men I just
want to say one of my favorite couples
and I know I'm probably alone in this is
amber and Barnett and you are alone and
I don't agree with what people are
saying about him like he is the token
fuck-boy like because he was [ __ ]
around three girls in the pod [ __ ]
around big easy they were just talking
so he's exploring that's what he's there
to do right and I I just liked amber I
liked her energy I liked her story and I
thought like when they saw each other
for the first time like I thought their
reactions were so sweet they were both
so excited each the each of them was
like hotter than the next amber looked
like the [ __ ] snatchler she went to
like [ __ ] the entire I mean
I was in the pod sweat sanity on TV I
didn't have her confession I was like so
it's like the way that you it's like
sometimes I won't even like take a phone
call if I am NOT like dress or had
makeup on because it's just the way that
you like feel about yourself so I
understand that but she just turned it
out it also seems like they had day
dates and night dates because I think
during the day dates who were allowed to
wear sweats but at night time is the
only time you could get proposed to
because everyone who was opposed to was
wearing a dress no it wasn't that they
were told when they were told a proposal
was gonna happen because they all got
dressed up and then I saw in one of the
producers instagrams that picture with
the producer and all of the girls in
their proposal dresses making it seem
like the purpose it was proposal day Oh
mm-hmm
interesting interesting um really
quickly about you Nina she's literally
one of my favorites but she almost lost
me when she proposed to Jamie and
because don't get me wrong I'm I am
totally a feminist like I really feel
like women are equal we're better
actually like I I can't stress that
enough but there are certain things and
there are certain gender roles that must
be applied like you know a woman carries
a baby and a man proposes like I just I
refuse to budge on that like I just in a
heterosexual relationship like I think
that that's how it should be and I just
think that like I loved her like her
message of being equal but he could you
a man kept approach to you and you could
still be equal yes so I just like hated
that because I think it was so great was
not for me either and when she was in
the pod like obviously I liked her
because she's so pretty but she was like
saying stuff that sounded like so
rehearsed it was giving me nice a it was
giving me my catnip vibes but she had
her like her like the Love Wins
empowerment speech where it's like she's
just right am i wrong and then
throughout the rest of the season like
Giannina just like says these things
that are so cringy and terrible grips
dude it's like she's an actress
I lost my butterflies Damien that's
called love actually get like doesn't
like being in a relationship and - what
marriages the butterflies are out the
window once your wife sometimes on a
cool winter's night hook comes back but
I'm sorry they're gone completely and so
do you get butterflies every time you
see Ben
every time we literally never never if
he brings food maybe I'm like oh that's
the food I'm just hungry it's what not
butterflies
so she I liked her despite her
flaws and she had so many like she was
so mean to Damien and in no way are they
perfect sergeant when she aired out like
their sad ass stuff and here's the thing
I appreciate it we're on TV
but it's clear that they have set film
times when they're meeting each other's
parents when they're doing like first
day blah blah blah I think they get a
lot of time off camera just to be
themselves and that's a conversation
that could've been had off camera
because it was just so embarrassing for
him it was so rude and she she just
treats him like [ __ ] like he to be
honest he's not the man first she's very
outgoing she's very outspoken Janet
laughing who is the man for her like
what kind of guy is the right guy for
her I feel like I relate to her on a lot
of levels like we both are very moody
like we get really angry we get really
happy like I feel like I related to her
in a lot of ways and Damien is too much
of a [ __ ] to deal with that like I
think that she he needs she needs
someone who's not on her level because
she's way out there but like who's a
little bolder like someone who won't
just roll over and like see in the
bedroom saying that he's boozy like yeah
it was terrible I don't know I related
to her because it's very hard for
someone with a strong personality like
find someone who matches their vibe and
that strong personality is like she
loves hard and she hates hard and some
of the [ __ ] listening to me [ __ ]
like she was nuts
yeah she was nuts but I love her yeah I
like her but she's losing me more and
more because I just feel like she's
being an actress yeah no I absolutely no
doubt they're that they're not together
and they they're not meant for each
other and I do think in the pods like
people would have a really strong
connection and feel like they love each
other but they also got engaged because
they wanted to like take this further
see what the person looks like and move
forward yeah also just because you
connect with someone on a super deep
level doesn't mean you're in love with
that like I have very deep connections
with friends like yeah so I think that's
something a lot of the couples are
experiencing like Kenny and Kelly I feel
like she didn't really say anything it
was all good until her bachelorette
party yeah something's amiss even though
if I was a betting woman I would put my
money on them making it same but what
she said I kind of understood she's like
I'm not sure if we're just like really
good friends because it's pop and that's
like what jessica keeps trying to say
about mark right it's possible for the
experiment to have worked but not for
love like you can really just get to
know someone without being in love or
sexually attracted to them that's why I
think a couple like amber and Barnett
and
Lauren and Cameron are really great
because they connected for sure and then
they saw each other and they were wowed
well we need to talk about the physical
I mean we need to talk about amber
burned out really quickly because I know
I I mean I don't even want to read the
comments I just I love her I love that I
know she's crazy and like um people are
saying saying she's like irresponsible
and blah but like I just I really she
soaked herself
so with Barnet like he's so in love with
him right so I didn't agree that like he
was being a fuck-boy I think he handled
all the situations in the best way that
he could the best way that he could and
he end up choosing someone and when dove
headfirst like if he had still been
wishy-washy like talking to Jessica like
I would've been like oh he's really a
fuck-boy but no like he played the field
found someone and then ran with her like
I don't think that's wrong I have no
problems with how he handled the pause I
think after the show I really realize
like what a catch he is like he's really
so cute his family so cute this house is
super great when he was talking to his
family about amber and like what he was
saying and he was like I know you don't
believe it for me but I did I'm this is
different like he was being so mature
and like in touch with his emotions and
I really feel I don't know if they're
still together now because maybe like it
could be a great relationship but is it
a marriage I found amber to be like a
little annoying like stop talking about
how much sex you're having like it's
like a third grader who just had sex for
the first time likes xxx I just found
that to be like stupid and immature and
I did have like a real problem with her
lifestyle like I know I'm not one to
judge anyone but you just like want to
be a stay-at-home mom when you're not
even dating anyway and she and even like
I'm sorry like when you're of a certain
age like you have to have some sort of
accountability for your life like she
didn't even have a house to go to like
just show him like they just showed his
house so like I just can't get on board
with someone who doesn't work has no
ambitions like just wants me to stay at
home on and then like has a $700 old two
credit card okay I would agree with you
but then I saw something in toeses mind
where she had posted on Facebook kind of
explaining the situation and that it's
not what you think
and okay I saved it because and by the
way I'm sympathetic to someone who's
like fallen on hard times she said she
was homeless for a while but he was
severely depressed about I mean they
might have just caught her at like a bad
time in her life okay she said I was out
this is from a facebook screenshot of
her name amber lynn pikes I'm assuming
it's her she said I was out of work cuz
I had a lawsuit out against my old job
over a workers comp injury I wasn't
paying on my student loans yet cuz I
just dropped out the year before because
of my depression from the abortion
I've never expected anyone to take care
of me ever that whole situation is out
of context I'd love to be a stay-at-home
mom once someday but that's a goal not
an expectation but I'm not delusional
delusional enough to think that that can
be achieved in this economy without two
people working for it don't believe
everything you see on TV also Netflix
was paid for the entire wedding the
budget I was talking about with the
budget they gave me the budget Netflix
save her so she was for hunters over
budget oh I was wondering that because
they all have the same caliber wedding
when they all came from different
socioeconomic backgrounds so I do think
that that is an important point also I
by the way I actually believe that she's
dead I'm more than disappointed with how
they portrayed me my mom called me
crying because she was convinced it was
because I was the only one on the show
that came from a poor background so they
made me out to be a money-grubber I
wasn't raised that way I didn't go
through boot camp at 17 because I'm the
kind of person that wants someone to
take care of me I do what I have to just
survive and always well I completely
believe I've never actually psyche stand
by that statement I feel like I totally
understand what she's saying
but someone in the toast is blind
Facebook group which I can't stress
enough how good it is they were they
were describing she was not in the army
she was in like the jewel shard the
guard the reserve or whatever which is a
once a month commitment and a bunch of
the people a bunch of the toasters in
the group were actually have been in
that - we're sure if you're active yet
you get like a huge college scholarship
so that she dropped out and then I read
yeah you don't get the money if you
don't complete your courses and then you
owe on it if you're an active member of
the military sure you can look down on
the National Guard but as people who are
just Libyans who just enjoy our freedoms
thanks to people that serve in the
National Guard I'm not here to judge at
what level she participated
that's very true I just thought it was
worth noting I agree there's a lot worth
noting and you know Jessica's friends
are in the ptosis buying Facebook group
saying she's not an alcoholic right
portrayed this way Jessica and her
friends are like literally working
overtime to blame production on and by
the way I'm a firm believer that
production and like the cutting room
floor can really affect like how we see
other people but so much of what I just
liked about Jessica had absolutely
nothing to do with editing it was just
like little nuances like I just think
that like her haircut no they're
touching of the hair no and like if you
want to put keep your hair in your face
get bangs not one length hair and
the whole show I was really thinking
like how much alcohol there was like
because honestly to to get along with
people you just met like you're staying
in a house with them for a week like I
totally understood how like wine wasn't
necessary it was like cool to like see
the girls like having a glass of wine
Jay my boyfriend's also like having
needs long deep conversations like a
glass of wine helps you open up I agree
and there was wine obviously in the pods
so I thought it was cool how there was
alcohol there actually likes out I think
it really helps people like open up and
be vulnerable but and they didn't see
anyone like literally ever feel or look
drunk but I saw Jessica look drunk many
times like in the pod you could tell
when her baby voice came out that she
was getting drunk the when she was talk
about how sexy Barnett is like after
that party when she had that
conversation with Barnett oh my god I
could have died I was and I just feel
like Barnett it's just like I made the
right choice like he has no regret no
and I like that he doesn't like [ __ ]
around I think then you could have
called him a [ __ ] boy if he had engaged
in these conversations with Jessica in
an inappropriate way but he was so
appropriate he saw how crazy she was
being he didn't indeed engage and he
told amber about it let's take a pause
and mute the mics for the errands
um what we sing he told amber about it
you know he really I think did
everything right I don't know why he's
getting this like he's being dragged on
Twitter like being a [ __ ] boy when I
totally disagree
he gives [ __ ] boys a good name yeah he's
a reformed [ __ ] boy like he came on
the show he really wants to find love
and I think that like he's totally sure
amber there's some red flags you know
she's not the most financially
responsible but I mean ladies we can
relate and that doesn't because that a
makeup trip you know it's the Sephora
rule of 120 dollars you can't get added
there for less than 120 dollars you know
I didn't think that was alarming at all
I just divide that I got was that like
she has no expectation of ever working
and she just wants to like roll into she
doesn't seem like I feel like she seems
like a strong woman I don't think that
of course yeah everyone like no one
wants to work that's why do you have a
job right um but I think it's me being
mean to be more than it is yeah I want
to talk about Cameron for a minute I
find him to be such an interesting fella
like a lot of people are saying that
they think the show is casted and that
it's like actors but people like Cameron
like you can't act that awkwardness like
you can't is so true to himself and I
love that he's like so like in this
place in this life like he has a
three-bedroom house and like Lauren's
just gonna like a role right in and I
follow Lauren on I know I looked at
Lauren's Instagram and it looks like she
posts a lot for him it sounds like I'm
almost a hundred percent sure that they
got married and actually like are
together forever I would love that for
that I would love that too her dad was
so [ __ ] scary like that conversation
was so painful like honestly like I felt
like the tension was so thick but I
thought he handled handled himself well
considering he's not like so outspoken
you know I think I did the right thing I
think him doing the show was like so out
of character for him I know but I love
the fact that we have a scientist like
the jobs are all so weird general
managers you know manager manager also
we never got an update to Damian lose
his job for being on the show unclear
but I did like how they address those
things also a mint went to meet Damian's
family and they were like the oppas
didn't want to be on camera no and they
just I were like what if what the [ __ ]
are you doing is this farce
yeah I feel that but it's annoying that
it put a strain on his relationship when
it literally has nothing to do with
Giannina agreed and she she was a little
nuts like just thinking everything was
about her and like the mascara I was
just like she was scary she's scary
yeah I like sure that you
um are we missing any other couples I
mean was Kelly and Kenny first of all me
they got this lucky airtime but they
have everything going for them like the
fact that they're so like on each
other's level into each other and then
she's like gonna go ahead and say that
like because he's not pretty nice she's
not attracted to him like how dare you
like he's so handsome he's so handsome I
would say they're on the same level he
might even be cuter than her like relax
Kelly I thought their families were so
cute yeah and they come from the same
family like they're they look I couldn't
tell whose parents room no it was so
beautiful to watch them all come
together and when the mom the moms were
like hugging and they were like you know
marriage is between two people but it's
so enriched when like the families
become one by the way I thought that
that was literally the most beautiful
sentiment I couldn't that's exactly what
it is like a marriage really is between
two people if they don't get along like
fine a marriage can't survive without
but the support and love of the people
around them really enriches a marriage I
thought that was like such a beautiful
sentiment no I agree it really stuck
with me but so then literally you
thought they were perfect until they're
about to wrap parties she's saying how
she thinks they're just friends and as
she's saying that they haven't had sex I
mean you know what at this point they've
been together for a month every single
day it's and so that's like 30 plus
dates when it's morning noon and night
and like I do think unless they were
saving themselves for marriage I think
that they should have they should have
sex before their wedding I would just
like to have a brief moment of silence
for the 31 year old virgin who got no
airtime other than to say it wasn't
right and so like he got nothing from
the show except for the embarrassment
world all these friends and family
knowing that he's the 31 year old virgin
so he would now be 33 and I'm just
curious if he ever found someone he made
me sad because like because he like in
order to this show wasn't put on by
Netflix like it was it was a production
company so it was not like the most
prestigious like it really these people
were taking a leap of faith and it was
all you know with the goal of finding
love and I felt like they were all even
the thirsty ones like we're there for
for a good reason like I didn't feel
like anyone was there to [ __ ] around so
to put yourself out there like that and
then to not only have it fail but like
to have like your most vulnerable moment
be the only thing people say about you
like he made me really sad yeah forgot
about it was like oh I just didn't want
to remember I thought about him all
night
oh my god that is so rough okay so now
that we like recapped it pretty much I'm
a few questions for you one
who do you think will back out mark and
Jessica
Jessica's definitely saying though she's
she's thirsty but the show's over so
she's not going through with it
Jessica's just saying no if she goes
through with it honestly she should be
arrested no no if she goes damn it that
like I actually would have respect for
her like no she's so [ __ ] indecisive
like no one has ever hated someone more
than she hates mark Oh completely and I
think like walking into his house made
her like level of hatred reach
astronomical levels with his one brown
pillow no and his roommate and their
beers like they're just on such
different planets sack that she could
only have a good conversation with him
but she was wrong looking at him or when
they recreate the pot oh yeah but what
was so interesting about their
relationship is that he is dating
multiple women because like sober her
and drunker so we're like can tolerate
him drunk her cannot no but it's weird
that when they like want to go back to
the pods it's like they were hostages
yeah yeah yeah who's only ten days you
know in order to like properly
communicate they have to be like in
separate rooms like relationships never
going to work and but even when Giannina
and damien were fighting in the kitchen
not looking at each other when he was in
the bed it's like they all revert back
to like this pot mentality I didn't
think that that it's by the way it's
definitely like it's the mole women like
it's so like how you only want to land
like a small bed I didn't think that G
Nina and Damien having that fight in
different rooms was that weird because
they were really communicating quite
well even though what she was saying was
cringy but it's because they they got
started and they're comfortable with
that but having it in order to have a
good time you need to be apart that's
weird
yes okay that's a very fair distinct
right like Damien and what's-her-name
are trying to say difficult things to
each other and sometimes it is easier
not to look someone in the face but in
order to have a good date you have to be
in separate rooms Jess can work that's
problematic yeah with their pepperoni
shaped confetti oh yeah that was bad
yeah okay
so I grade mark and Jessica should not
be getting married if they do like I'm
sorry I will riot um I don't think that
I think maybe
Janina and Damien get married but break
up shortly there there's no way they're
together
because of anything I thought that she
would say no so we have her saying yes
and then we could seem like he's gonna
say no but I think that he was gonna say
no they would have had him say no and
then in the episode because it's like
what right you know but I think it'll
just be a yes I think this yes I think
Kenny and Kellie say yeah
and I think there's a small chance that
they're still together Jessica and Mark
definitely not the only one I'm really
unsure about is Amber and Barnet I mean
we see there's only one blonde woman so
we see Kelly running out and then she
falls down the hill in a wedding dress
she runs out of the way yeah yeah so
like she's obviously like going out with
a bang which totally respect Barnet and
Amber's the only one I'm not sure about
because there really is like such a
physical connection there and it was
sparked by an emotional connection so I
just think that their socioeconomic
backgrounds like are playing a factor
and like how they perceive each other
yeah I think I think but I don't think
she would say no no I think his
background makes her like him more and
her background makes him like her less I
feel like his background well I'm sure
she's like excited that he could take
care of her I feel like it really
intimidates her and like makes her feel
like not you know I feel like she
actually would have maybe liked him more
if if they came from similar backgrounds
no I think she like liked what she saw
interesting it's exciting she couldn't
own it down for the family you know like
oh yeah you need to be yourself but like
and I don't think she has any problems
expressing herself but when you do meet
someone's parents like you are you're
buttoned up like church-going version of
yourself like there's certain situations
in life when you have to be an actress
and it's like and he tells her like my
family doesn't drink alcohol and they're
like oh how do you deal with the
pressure and she drink alcohol like
that's just you know agree common sense
ya know everyone should always be
themselves but sometimes you could be
yourself like a little bit less a
hundred percent so I I agreed and by the
way why did they go to Amber's house and
not go inside I think that her family
was really skeptical of the process yeah
you know and I didn't think they wanted
to be judged I'm judging her mom she was
so [ __ ] cute I'm judging her with
love you know her family seemed really
sweet yeah they really did understaffed
job like this seems like they have a
good relationship like I thought I was
super cute I thought I really liked
amber I feeling her house was fine it
wasn't a trailer like people are just
being so dramatic with like the they're
trying to delete it yeah they're trying
to make it like sincerity
yeah but I think they're trying to like
emphasize the age difference is the
racial differences the socio-economic
differences yeah so that we can really
see if love is blind right and I think
the the only couple who I think are
successful and we're the only couple who
really had adversity to face was Cameron
and Lauren yeah I think they're
definitely together it's just so funny
because
love really is mine because if I knew
these two people I'd never would have
pegged him like Lauren yeah definition
of opposites attract she's outgoing
she's funny she's hilarious I could she
was talking her French was making me
laugh so much and Cameron is like a
freak so they're just like I would never
pin the two as being compatible but
that's where the experiment becomes
interesting so if I have any notes for
the next season if there's gonna be one
I would like one maybe two more episodes
in the pods I feel like the episodes in
the apartment were so dragged out like I
was getting so bored it was literally
day 19 for two episodes like I found
that to be so painful and I I think the
beginning of the show was the most
compelling and the most heartfelt and I
felt like I just liked watching them all
communicate and I felt rushed because it
was so I could have dealt because
towards the end because we're all
relying on these pod connections and for
us like we didn't get to see enough of
that thing that we're relying on yep
like and what made these people like so
bonded aside from Chicago Labs Christian
yeah so I would have loved more time in
the pods and less time in the real world
and I think the the expectation of a
marriage was a little um bachelor II I
think there's like that pressure I do
because otherwise you both stay together
and [ __ ] around until the show's over
but no do you want to [ __ ] get
married are you gonna put your money
where your mouth is do you want to make
a life together
I guess but it made it feel silly like
with that woman
ordained minister like was these such
gems of a whole time okay at that point
it like the way they look at joy was a
soap opera yeah yeah and the wedding was
so fake like I just find a way to make
it that seem less like People's Court
yes yeah it was Judge Judy like it was
so inauthentic I almost think maybe it
would be better if the expectation at
the end was an engagement because I
think everyone would go along for the
ride but you know what to put that like
stain on your marriage record yeah
that's that's a big commitment and you
love this person enough to have to tell
a future partner oh I got married on a
reality show I'm that kind of person
right that's true actually
so I actually I like that they have to
take that leap yeah it's just towards
the end if like I started the show by
being so invested emotionally and I felt
like it was like a really heartfelt
compelling show and by the end it just
it got to the level of silliness at the
bachelors at that's like why we love the
back you know that's why
mobs love is not like I understand it
there's it's realistic to a point but at
a certain point if this is TV it's
entertainment like it's not meant to be
just like your regular relationship
everything is accelerated there really
are going through life in 30 days
they're really having like these intense
conversations real fights painful fights
it's like there's a reason we don't see
a lot of fights on The Bachelor the
logistics of the show I also found to be
come on come here though
I found the logistics to be interesting
and they didn't really explain how I
think that they cast everyone solely
about solely from people who lived in
Georgia because I like that I'd like
that too because then it's like The
Bachelor problem it's like people fall
in love and then one lives in Canada and
one lives in Florida like it's not
realistic so I liked it they all lived
in Atlanta even though they were from
different places it took me a while to
figure out I'm like Camryn lives in
Maine how are they in Maine they were
just in Atlanta yeah but then I realized
they all currently live in Atlanta and I
think that made the short show more
believable more believable and I do feel
like your geographical location it has a
lot on who you end up with so maybe
these people would have met in another
life because they live in Atlanta yeah
so I liked that I like that as well just
as for the 31 year old virgin okay and
one more question for you is love blind
I think it can be I don't think it's a
definite no or yes because I think
there's definitely success with Cameron
and Lauren I think it can be blind and I
just think it's actually an interesting
dating approach like I think that like
if you did like a speed-dating with
blinds like I think it's really
interesting I do really firmly believe
that an emotional connection can create
a physical one like I think that you can
meet someone and not be attracted to
them but if you got to know them from a
blind like level and then you met them
in a real person you would think that
they were hotter than you did before you
knew them so I think that premise is
really interesting and could be true and
if love is blind do you think that love
is enough to overcome whatever obstacles
once you have no know some types of love
are enough I don't think love is enough
no life is too hard and honestly the
premise of the show is kind of
depressing because love is not enough
like life and money and family like that
ruins I know a million marriages who got
called off who they really loved each
other but the external forces made it
impossible yeah and love is not enough
love is it's not enough and if you want
to run our way to an island together it
could be enough yeah you but then all
the reasons why you fell in love with
each other like you're you know your
friends and your family
the life that you built your job on and
then your the two of you are just stuck
with each other and I don't think love
is enough and I think that's really the
moral of the story of the book movie
Anna Karenina when she opens her entire
life for love and then like she's so
miserable cuz she ruined her life from
yeah I love it it's just not enough you
guys um I'm excited the one the one that
I have a lot of uncertainty about is
Amber and Burnett and I'm excited to see
how that ends I'm praying for them but
like it doesn't look good actually
they're all their instagrams are weird
I'm not gonna judge based on like the
fact that I'm trying not to look at the
Instagram yeah but it doesn't tell you
anything which is scary like Amber's
Instagram she posts like once a year and
there's no sign of barn absence she's
not thirsty then yeah she's not um okay
so the finale drops on Thursday and
Friday we will obviously be recapping it
when when Netflix releases things
episodically when does it come out
Wednesday night I'm wondering that
you're loving episodic times now um I
guess Wednesday night we'll see
hopefully we can recap it on Thursday
but we also need to give time for
everyone to watch it so Friday um but
thank you so much listening to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it
Spotify iTunes stitcher public video I
have rated cashbox oh the places where
you can listen to a podcast so ever you
choose to listen to podcasts find us the
morning to us hi how are you
leave a comment maybe a review a
subscription five stars about how
beautiful setting in smart we are I
don't know it's up to you have an
amazing day and just remember love isn't
blind